here we go college Roadshow gotta bring
our AGame what is the most inspiring
thing I ever said to you don't be an
idiot
changed my life whenever I'm about to do
something I think would an idiot do that
and if they would I do not do that thing
okay we can start you're waiting for me
yeah Pam you're a member of this family
so we won't wait for our family members
tell us you want to give it a shot I got
it when my mother was pregnant with me
they did an ultrasound and found she was
having twins when they did another
ultrasound a few weeks later they
discovered that I had resorbed the other
fetus do I regret this no I believe his
tissues made me stronger I don't have
the strength of a grown man and a little
baby okay why don't you throw the ball
to somebody else nope y'all ed was
decapitated
he was drunk as a skunk he was flying
down Route six he slides under an
18-wheeler pop it snaps right off that
is the way to go instant death a very
smart you know a human can go on living
for several hours after being
decapitated you're thinking of a chicken
what did I say hey hey if my head ever
comes off I would like you to put it on
ice I do not want to talk about this
when I die I want to be frozen and if
they have to freeze me in pieces so be
it
I will wake up stronger than ever
because I will have used that time to
figure out exactly why I died and what
moves that could have used to defend
myself better now that I know what hold
he had me in do we all have our copy of
threat level midnight by Michael Scott
alright let's get this started I'm gonna
be reading the action descriptions and
Phyllis I would like you to play captain
Z - Jones
that's the characters well you guys
should not be doing this
why not Dwight this is a movie I mean
this is for all of America to enjoy you
took something that doesn't belong to
you
Dwight brought it in here do you want
seven to play the lead role of Agent
Michael Scarn beside the FBI agent
Michael Scarn sits with his feet up on
his desk Catherine zeta-jones enters sir
you have some messages not now they're
important okay
what are they first message is I love
you that's for me not in a thousand
years Catherine we work together and get
off my desk yes I have acted before I
was in a production of Oklahoma in the
seventh grade I played the part of mutti
the mailman they had too many kids so
they made up roles like that that was
good
okay that is not an eight-foot sub we
don't make an eight-foot sub this is a
one-foot subs all right what's the
damage 3960 3960 whitetip someone for a
job I'm capable of doing myself I can
deliver food I can drive a taxi I can
and do cut my own hair I did however tip
my urologist because I am unable to
pulverize my own kidney stones what did
I do
I did my job i slashed benefits to the
bone I saved this company money was I
too harsh maybe I don't believe in
coddling people in the wild there is no
health care in the wild health care is
how I hurt my leg
I can't run a lion needs me and I'm dead
well I'm not dead I'm the lion you're
dead okay I will only need two things a
roll of duct tape and a knife I'm on it
okay 30 minutes relax please come back
save the receipts Hey what hey wait wait
I keep various weaponry strategically
placed around the office I saved Jim's
life with a can of pepper spray
I had velcroed under my desk people say
oh it's dangerous to keep weapons in the
home or the workplace well I say it's
better to be hurt by someone you know
accidentally than by a stranger on
purpose
two o'clock in the afternoon really
beating down on me now I think that I
want to get a little more comfortable
because the Sun is depleting my
resources but I will never help him I
will lead armed befall him I will even
let him die but I will never let him
lose his dignity there we go much better
Michael is a man of great depth and
passion I don't know what he's searching
for out here I hope he finds it
watch
nothing to worry about just using the
scope safety is on here are some things
that I want to teach you that your
mother won't be able to jumpstart a car
first pop the hood then you take these
bad boys and clip them anywhere on the
engine then you take these and clip them
wherever number 8 learn how to take off
a woman's bra what we will demonstrate
on Pam no and no one you just twist your
hand until something breaks oh well you
get the picture
thanks Pam and remember no matter what I
will always love you
what if he's a murderer you're not gonna
be a murder maybe that's how you die you
know what Dwight do you want to do this
or no I want to do with this okay from
the top
ready three action why all these people
here too many people in this earth we
need a new plague moralize people
you know what I bet loves our wedding
crashers no way Trevor's handling me of
course I saw it I saw wedding crashers
accidentally I bought a ticket for
Grizzly Man and went into the wrong
theater after an hour I figured I was in
the wrong theater but I kept waiting
that's the thing about bear attacks they
come when you least expect it you know I
just wish I wish I had the investigative
powers to actually smoke something these
guys out you know once again Jim I will
take care of this I will locate the
wedding crashers and report them to
Phil's that way I won't have to get her
a gift I accidentally ran over it it's a
Christmas miracle
well get it out of here relax okay and
because this is Christmas I am going to
roast this goose and prepare it with a
wild rice dressing do we have any
cayenne pepper in the kitchen Merry
Christmas 20 Jim wow what we got here
what does it look like dead goose and
circle gets the square so can you watch
this I'm gonna get my carving knife out
of the trunk do I always talked about
this no Toby this is different he's
already dead once I brought in a duck to
prepare for lunch and people got upset
apparently they got attached to the duck
and didn't want to see it killed he was
already dead and we schrutes use every
part of the goose the meat has a
delicious smoky rich flavor plus you can
use the molten goose grease and save it
in the refrigerator thus saving you a
trip to the store for a can of expensive
goose grease Wow when when exactly thank
you Jim
that's you sir thank you I never let
anyone walk behind me seven out of ten
attacks are from the rear
okay well that still leaves a 30% chance
that I'll attack you from the front yeah
but it'll be easier to stop I can always
block the blow I can counter it but fear
is what it's all about you cannot sell
while undergoing fear you need to
vanquish fear one must wrestle fear to
the ground you're doing this is over
right get in the bunker Ryan hi Ryan
you seem nice
you